[Applause]
hello hello it is true I am mr. K
teacher and if anyone didn't get the
joke that is a reference to the fact
that we are husband and wife in addition
to being colleagues in the world of
journalism
thank you I wanted a softball interview
[Laughter]
and it is a recent vintage only three
weeks old and I will I will hope to
avoid which means there are no marital
issues to work out here on stage yet
it's too new for that I was hoping to
get a sense from the audience of how
many people here already have read the
book and how many of not how many have
read the book so we have a lot of
curious may be on the fence buyer so I
think that's helpful because we can
start with things that go to the
beginning of this story because the
Donald Trump trajectory and the Katy tur
trajectory are entwined in a very
fascinating way and in the very same way
that he is a political neophyte who made
unexpected progress in his primary
campaign and became president Katy here
was not a political reporter when all
this began so could you tell the nice
people what it was that you were doing i
I reserve judgment on whether they're
nice until after they buy the book buy
the book
so I was a foreign correspondent for NBC
News that was living in London and I
just came back to New York for a couple
days to remind my bosses that I exist
because you may have a tendency to
forget you when you're overseas unless
there's some major news happening and it
happened to be a slow period and I
showed up in the newsroom and I'm
standing around just chatting with one
of my colleagues and Donald Trump was
making headlines he had just announced
that he was running for president and in
doing so said Mexico was sending rapists
the country so Macy's dropped the Donald
Trump brand from its stores Univision
said we're not going to air your pageant
any longer NBC said we're not gonna air
your pageant any longer either and this
was a ballooning story that needed to be
covered and they needed someone to cover
it but they're not gonna put one of
their political reporters on it because
why would you put a political reporter
on Donald Trump I mean he's a sideshow
he's gonna be done in a few days
so they said who's around to do this and
someone yelled out Katie she's just
standing around which I was and I ended
up covering one story than two then
three and on by the third or fourth day
I got told that the president of NBC
News wanted to assign me the campaign
full-time and I freaked out IIIi thought
a myriad of things one I was living
overseas and that was not living in New
York - I have a vacation in Sicily in a
week and a French boyfriend who I'm
supposed to go on it with I'm sorry Tony
and oh my god they don't take me
seriously if they're gonna put me on the
Donald Trump campaign they must think
I'm a joke as well but I called the
friend of mine who had covered Mitt
Romney in 2012 and and he had been
urging me to do a political campaign at
least once because he said it was unlike
anything else you will do it's grueling
but it's fascinating I called him and he
urged me to do it after he stopped
laughing because it was Donald Trump and
so I said yes and I was assured by my
boss one of my boss is that it'll be six
weeks tops
and then he said and if he goes to the
White House
you'll be White House correspondent he
starts laughing steps into an elevator
door and the elevator doors shut the
important thing is a cinematic in its
moment and and you know it's not an
important assignment when the
conversation takes place in a hallway as
elevator doors shut yeah they come to my
office in the beginning Trump was having
gatherings that would later become the
spectacular packed rallies that cable
networks would carry in their entirety
but they were much much smaller and you
were actually I think the very first one
or one of the very first ones in New
Hampshire could you talk a little bit
about that and in contrast to what most
of us have seen later and also the the
interesting way in which Trump and you
seem to be in a dynamic from the very
beginning so um the first round later I
went to was one of the first Donald
Trump rallies and and this was around a
backyard pool at a private home in New
Hampshire there was about a couple
hundred people remember at this time
nobody was taking his candidacy
seriously they thought that he was just
trying to get some attention and it was
confusing because people brands were
were companies were dropping him why was
he trying to get all this negative
attention so the assumption was he
wouldn't last to the debates and even if
he did he would get he would get laughed
offstage and he probably wouldn't want
to release his financials since he's so
notoriously secretive about his money so
at this backyard pool where there are
only a couple hundred people it mostly
was just people wondering what in the
world Donald Trump was doing I mean he
was on stage rambling he had no coherent
thread for for why he was campaigning
except for I want to build a wall and I
believe that Mexico is sending rapists
and the media didn't caveat me with some
more good people and I get more standing
ovations than anybody and
Katy tur you're not paying attention in
the middle of all in the middle of all
this and I remember thinking I
presumably wasn't even talking to me
because I've never I'd never met him
I'd never shared the same air as him
there was no reason in my mind for
Donald Trump to know who I was and my
producer gave me a hard nudge because
the entire place is looking at me and as
is Donald Trump and I just yelled out
I'm tweeting what you're saying which I
was doing and which he approved of
because he said I was doing a good job
and then he moved on but that became the
dynamic between the two of us and that
was the very first day him calling me
out while he was on stage either for
work that he approved of or more often
than not work that he disapproved of why
do you think he took a particular
interest in you from the beginning I
think
what you all have your assumption but
then I'll add this Donald Trump wants to
be taken seriously and I was the very
first network correspondent assigned to
cover his campaign full-time and that is
an honor when you're a presidential
candidate that means that a TV news
network a broadcast network and
something with the legacy of NBC News
has decided to assign a reporter
full-time to you so that means they're
taking you seriously so he he must have
seen me as somebody very early on that
he wanted to charm into submission
somebody that he could rely on for
favorable coverage also remember were
NBC News and he has a long-standing
relationship with NBC because we aired
The Apprentice and then there were large
swathes of time before any other
correspondents were assigned to cover
him full-time so we would I would go to
cities across this country where I would
be the only recognizable face in a room
for Donald Trump other reporters that
would come up to him for interviews were
mostly local reporters that and he
didn't know who they were so we ended up
engaging one on one quite a bit and he
came to pay much more attention to my
reporting than I he probably would have
had I started the campaign in December
or January when there were more
correspondence so in the beginning you
stayed in the US and you gave up an
Italian vacation a French boyfriend a
beautiful apartment in London a job as a
foreign correspondent which holds a
great deal of cachet is exciting
involves a lot of airline miles to
follow Donald Trump a person at that
time virtually everybody in the
political world can consider to be a
joke why would you give up so much to
cover what appeared to be so little I'm
still struggling to figure that out and
and and you know Tony because I wasn't
in the picture in the
every few weeks I I look at you and I
say we really need to move back to its
true I love that job it was a it was a
the dream job for me a foreign
correspondent the pinnacle of my career
I mean being a foreign correspondent for
a legacy news network is is an extremely
coveted job I mean you get to travel the
world you get to meet people you would
never get to meet and you get to do it
while somebody else pays for it I mean
it's it's perfect but did you see
something in the beginnings of Trump
that made you think this is going to be
worth it so where this is going to be
important initial II it was it was a
six-week assignment so I figured there
was nothing to lose and as it continued
he became I guess more captivating
fascinating I mean this was a roller
coaster and I wasn't about to you know
get off the ride nobody understood what
he was trying to achieve or why so many
people were so excited by him and people
are still trying to figure that out to
this day and I got to see it and and try
to understand it myself and I wasn't
going to say no to that and also being
overseas again when it gets slow you can
tend to be forgotten and there's a line
in the book where while I was very happy
overseas it's a it's a quote you know
from it from another person saying why
be happy when when you can be great and
that's kind of what I was thinking in
that moment I have an opportunity to do
something great to make a mark to to see
history unfold before my eyes it's a
cliche but that's really what a lot of
us get into the business to do to watch
history in the making and Donald Trump
love him or hate him was history in the
making he was up ending every norm
he was defying political gravity he was
pissing people off and he was exciting
so many others but everybody thought
that he was going to plummet after a
certain point after Iowa
to the fall there were all these lines
in the sand that the political
prognosticators would say after that
point it's a cliff for him you and I can
attest to this because I worked for NBC
and MSNBC Wall she was covering Trump
and you were we met in the makeup room
we did make we met in the makeup room
you were a lone voice of skepticism
against the political opinion that he
was going to burn out and crash why were
you so confident as a political neophyte
on those calls those morning editorial
calls to say something is happening here
I wasn't confident I mean I I started
out with a bit of a pipsqueak voice she
what were you seeing that me there were
there was enthusiasm and there was
devotion in a way that that the other
political candidates were not receiving
I mean he went after John McCain I mean
can you remember a time where a an
American politician anybody frankly in
the public eye that where they went
after an a veteran or a prisoner of war
an American war hero and were able to to
not only get away with it but to see
their popularity rise that is unheard of
in American politics you don't go after
a veteran at student you just do not do
it especially within the Republican
Party you don't do it and John and and
Donald Trump did and he got disinvited
from a bunch of Republican events but
his poll numbers went up and a few weeks
later when he went to Mobile Alabama
20,000 people showed up for him in
Mobile Alabama he said it was 40,000 he
was lying it was 20,000 pointless live
he always lies about the numbers if it's
if it could be a hundred thousand people
and he'll but there were 190 thousand
people there he has to yes almost double
it but it goes to show you that there
was something about Donald Trump that
made whatever he said even if it was
terribly offensive
it didn't matter people liked it
and I would get on the calls and and
people who have been doing politics
forever who are well respected who I
respect very much to this day and who've
seen it all happen before who know how
things go
said this is silly season I mean it's
summer people aren't paying attention by
the time the fall rolls around football
will be back on TV they won't want to
watch a Donald Trump rally homeland will
be on TV they won't want to watch the
Donald Trump rally it's Christmas know
people are gonna be being that they're
gonna be with their families by January
they're gonna get serious about politics
Donald Trump could never win but these
crowds that would show up to his events
were still huge and they were still so
excited to see him let's talk about that
anybody in the room been to a Donald
Trump rally
we got one person in the back two three
I would say fewer than 2% of the
audience has been to a rally so for the
sake of the 98% of the people who've
only seen it on TV what is it like to be
in the middle of a Donald Trump rally
and really the middle caged in with the
other journalists well
first off a lot of the time when you're
watching a rally on television something
he'll say will sound very offensive and
you'll presume that the room is not with
him oh this is a this is where he
crossed a line maybe the cameras aren't
picking up the audio in the room where
they're just focused on him and you just
you can't tell what's happening and what
people how people are responding and
there were multiple instances of this
where he would say something like you
know there was a crying baby and I'm
like get the baby out of here and he was
clearly joking but on on TV it didn't
really ring that way or if somebody
tweeted something it's not how it read
but he never lost any room that he was
in except for one time he never lost any
room that he was in even when he was
saying why truly wild stuff he was
calling Ben Carson a serial liar and
making some sort of comparison to a
child molester in the process and making
fun of him for the belts and the
stabbing and it was like it was on
believable in the moment even to the
reporters we were like what in the god's
name i cut myself
what in god's name is donald trump doing
i mean can he get away with this I
remember calling The Today Show and it
was late at night and saying you've got
to cover this in the morning this is
crazy he did this and that and this and
people don't care and they don't care
they like it and these were Ben Carson
supporters too there were people who
were saying I'm deciding between Donald
Trump and Ben Carson people who were
evangelicals in Iowa who really looked
up to ben Carson because he's a leader
in the evangelical community and Donald
Trump was just eviscerating him and
calling him names and calling him a liar
and we we talked to them afterwards and
they were like well you know he's got a
point and so I mean the he justified all
of the odds so my point is these rooms
were always with him and it wasn't just
the the Trump rallies it was people that
I would meet in in diners in gas
stations in airports cab drivers cab
drivers became my bellwether for how
well Donald Trump was doing and I could
tell you cab drivers in New York City
cab drivers in Washington DC cab drivers
in Miami cab drivers in Oh God I you
know all the states flanking on the
specific ones st. Louis they were
generally in North Carolina they
generally nine times out of 10 were
Donald Trump supporters so all walks of
life - for those who don't know Katie's
book is a memoir it is not an effort to
tell a complete story of the inside
workings of the Trump campaign or of the
whole election it is her perspective on
all of it and what it was like to be her
for 510 days on the Trump campaign and
because it is a memoir I'd like to hear
you talk a bit about how you thought
about covering Donald Trump and how you
dealt with the criticism his camp put on
you and your colleagues and whether any
of the criticism of the media that the
Trump campaign currently pursues and
still
- is is fair I think you watched my my
TV show too much because you just asked
me seven questions and one well no
they're good no I rejected the criticism
it's a this is now we're now a cable
news show here we're gonna do it just
ask the first question that's the first
question how did I do you think you
covered Donald Trump fairly and
accurately and how did you think about
that coverage I think I covered Donald
Trump thoroughly and accurately I think
I was tough on Donald Trump
day in and day out him which is part of
the reason why he kept calling me out on
stage I think he deserves deserved tough
coverage I think anybody who runs for
President to serve deserves about as
tough of coverage as you can give them
because they're running to lead this
country and you want to be as thorough
as you possibly can be both on the
Republican side and the Democratic side
independent side doesn't matter that
person needs to be fully fully vetted by
the press even if it makes you
uncomfortable because it's your chosen
candidate so I think I did it fairly and
it was difficult because he would say
things that were demonstrably untrue
over and over and over again and then
there were times where he got treated he
did get treated unfairly in a certain
rally or from a certain perception and
we would have to go on TV and say no he
really was joking and let me tell you
what was happening in the room because
it wasn't read well didn't read
correctly on TV or online but criticism
of the media in general for the way that
we covered Donald Trump I do think that
we need to look back at 2016 to figure
out how to do 2020 how to make sure we
do it as well as we possibly can I do
think that involves not just coverage of
the candidates and not just a you know a
a good rinsing of their opinions a good
wash and rinse of their opinions and
their policies and their behavior but
also covering the voters a little bit
more I think we could have done a better
job talking to people every day and not
just talking about putting them on
television every
single day and talking about the issues
that they cared about in their
communities because all politics are
local and each community was voting
based on what they wanted to change in
their community and that's why so many
unlikely voters for Donald Trump came
out on November 8th and in places where
you expected a Democrat to win places
where Obama won twice people who voted
for President Obama twice ended up
voting for Donald Trump because of
economic issues and they they decided
wilfully to ignore all of the outrageous
things he said and did because they were
looking for a the hope and change that
they were promised the previous eight
years they didn't see it happening in
their communities they didn't see their
quality of life improve and there was a
feeling like Donald Trump might despite
all of his many issues might be the
person who can go in and shake the
system up there was a gamble that was
done for a lot of people and we need to
in 2020 ask those people if they think
that their gamble paid off
I covered Trump rallies on the outside
covering the voters who were going in
and there was a time when the outside of
the rallies were so violent that riot
police were routinely a part of the
control where fights would break out
we're ugly ugly things were yelled and
then on the inside it sometimes seemed
it was even worse what how safe did you
feel in the middle of those crowds when
Donald Trump himself was pointing and
hissing in your direction by name you
you compartmentalize you and you covered
one rally I think on the inside while I
was hiding in Miami for a day you you
compartmentalize you tried not to let it
get you and people would come up to the
to the pen and scream obscenities at us
day in and day out they would call us
names call us Liars say that we should
be harmed physically
spin on us I mean any sort of behavior
you can imagine that happened towards
the press and there were times where we
all I mean we were all more guarded
towards into the campaign than we would
be a little more on edge than we would
because you just can't help it but there
were times where people really felt like
their safety was on the line there was a
rally in New Orleans where protesters
stopped the rally and the crowd got
really ugly and someone was tripped or
they were pushed or something but it
seemed like the whole crowd was about to
tumble into the press pen which is just
this bicycle rack gated off area and the
middle of the of the rally
so that was one moment there was one
moment for there were a number of
moments but the the one that comes to
mind I write about in the book was the
Muslim Band day from December 12 2015
this was in South Carolina Mount
Pleasant South Carolina and were in the
the belly of a World War two battleship
and to give you an idea of what was
happening at that time a few weeks
earlier
San Bernardino had happened the
terrorist attack in San Bernardino and
in response to it President Obama gave a
speech on terrorism to the country and
the following day the following Monday
Donald Trump is not dominating the
headlines because we're talking about
President Obama and terrorism and he
comes out midday without any sort of
warning without any sort of heads-up and
makes an announcement through a press
release that says he wants to ban all
Muslims from coming into the country and
we had interviewed at people that were
waiting to get into this rally to find
out if they felt it was a good or bad
idea this was people presume that this
was just a bridge too far that this was
going to sink him he couldn't possibly
try to ban an entire religion of people
from coming into the country it's
anti-american I don't wanna interrupt
this story but I do want to have you
mention where you were and what it's
like when major news of on the
presidential level happens and your day
goes to go sideways we're in South
Carolina so you can imagine a
I'm enjoying a really good lunch one of
the you know there were few and far
between so we were at a we were just
coming back from from lunch at at a
great place in South Carolina stuffing
ourselves with delicious fried food and
I we went back to the hotel ally Batali
my Donald Trump embed with for NBC News
and if you get the book you'll
understand what that means and we ran
into another one of our colleagues who
is on his computer and the email from
the campaign popped up on his computer
30 seconds before it came to our phones
and his face just like turns white and
he jaw drops it's cartoonish and he
starts laughing and that like
uncomfortable way you laugh when you
just can't believe something's in front
of your eyes and Ali and I looked at him
and said what in the world are you
looking at tell us tell us tell us and
he's like look at your look at your
phones and so we start furiously
refreshing our email and then it this
comes over Donald J Trump is announcing
a ban on all Muslims and no sooner did I
did I have the phone in my hand and read
it then my phone started ringing it was
it was MSNBC saying you got to go live
she describes the phone as a shot caller
in the book kind of is and if any of you
were watching cable news for the
campaign or MSNBC you'll know that we
were on TV constantly every single hour
on the hour and this was one of those
blessed days where I had like a three
hour break so I actually could eat lunch
and my phone rings and they and they
said you got to get on TV and walk us
through this and I'm like I don't know
anything about it I mean I just got it
in my phone I I haven't had a chance to
call the campaign and I got to call my
sources but that doesn't matter when
you're in the world of 24/7 news
coverage they need you on TV immediately
they need you trying to explain even the
unexplainable and so I call in and Kate
snow and I and I found this old tape
Kate snow and I talked for 10-15 minutes
tried of trying to figure out what this
statement means and how it might affect
Donald Trump's campaign or how might
voters respond to it or how might the
Republican Party or the Democratic Party
or the political establishment respond
to it were tap dancing
and just coincidentally MSNBC had come
out with a poll that day that showed
that Republican voters the the thing
that they feared the most their biggest
fear was being the victim of a terrorist
attack so there was there was that and
how is that gonna sway Donald Trump
supporters opinions where has Donald
Trump been before this why would he be
doing this at this particular moment bla
bla bla
so we rushed to the the venue do these
interviews with supporters outside and
then go inside to wait for Donald Trump
to arrive and people are angry they're
scared as I mentioned San Bernardino had
just happened and Donald Trump had been
saying and what and was saying with this
announcement that the Obama
administration wasn't vetting people
they weren't vetting people who were
coming into the country and that's why
these terrorist attacks are happening
they're gonna happen more often
Muslims are building bombs in their
living room their Muslim neighbors
aren't telling the authorities about it
they are hiding them and the media is
complicit because the media isn't
reporting on it they are not reporting
on the failures of the Obama
administration so the room was scared
the room was angry and we couldn't find
anybody who thought that this was a bad
idea the most we got was I've got to
think about it the the me on the other
end of the spectrum it was what would be
even better would be if we deport all
Muslims and and at the time that Donald
Trump is making this announcement he's
also conducting a Twitter feud with you
and another reporter yeah he was upset
about a tweets that I sent out literally
tweets that I sent out a few days
earlier at a rally in Raleigh say that
10 times fast a rally in Raleigh there
are funny points in the book it's not
just serious political stuff there's
some funny moments where we're a bunch
of protesters got organized and they
kept interrupting his speech over and
over and over again at like 5 to 10
minute
intervals enough to where he abruptly
stopped talking and left left the stage
to shake hands with people and I said
this on Twitter and he was furious about
it hope Hicks sent an email saying mr.
Trump thought your tweets were
disgraceful not nice best hope and and
after said that email he followed up by
going online on on his Twitter feed and
tweeting out that I am a liar and I'm
dishonest and I should be fired in a
series of I think five tweets something
like that five tweets and so my Twitter
feed is full of people calling me a liar
and saying I'm disgusting and making fun
of me and my family and and also death
threats so when you were and it jumps
from the digital world to the real world
in the belly of that battleship so we're
in the belly of the battleship as sorry
we're jumping around hope you're
following as as Donald Trump is getting
on stage to make this announcement this
Muslim band announcement and it is the
the atmosphere is tense I mean it's a
tinderbox you you throw a match in and
the whole place would light on fire it
is eight I don't want to say a scary
room but it's the kind of room where
it's best to keep a low profile so I'm
sitting I'm like sitting on the the
platform where the cameras are the
cameras are all above so I'm just kind
of keeping my head down because he had
called me out I didn't want to I didn't
want to be visible where I didn't want
to be as visible as I normally normally
am standing in front of the camera so
tonal tronca takes the stage and he
starts with his poll numbers as he
always does and and before he gets the
Muslim band he starts talking about the
media and then he's saying what a lie it
was as if the room knew what he was
talking about what alliant was from Katy
tur she's back there little Katy he's
pointing and I'm like sitting right here
and the speech is live on every cable
channel because it's a Muslim band and
everyone's trying to figure out what was
going on so it's live and the entire
room thousands of people turn at once
and start booing at me screaming in
person saying that
things that they were saying online but
saying them to my face and it was
nerve-racking my phone again starts
going off like crazy not just people on
Twitter but my colleagues and my bosses
and my mom saying what in the world is
happening cuz she's watching it on
television are you safe are you okay I
mean she's concerned but I put my her my
phone off I put it down I put it over
here because I got a job to do he's
making a major announcement how do you
keep doing that job when that kind of
attention well so here's I learned at
this point cuz he had gone after me so
many times
I'd learned at this point that in order
to defuse the situation you smile a new
wave so I did that I smiled and I waited
this angry crowd and eventually they got
bored by screaming at me and they turned
around how were you personally angry at
for entering you in that way
in the moment you let it go because you
have a job to do especially on that
night you let it go you have a job to do
that's what I just kept doing I'm not a
part of the story let it go I knew that
that would make me a part of the story I
was frustrated by it I didn't want to be
a part of the story
I did not want Chris Matthews to ask me
about it on TV two seconds later which
he did I although it is true that she
kept the stories in the book are not
stories that were told live on MSNBC you
saved all of them and put them in this
volume and before we go to questions
from the audience and speaking of doing
your job I am I love the fact that you
were one of the first people in America
to know about the Access Hollywood tape
they grab them by the pee more
interesting today isn't it than it was
even a you're vaccinating it's a
fascinating chapter in your story and I
love the journalistic process of having
to get comment from the Trump campaign
so when you're a journalist you have to
you find something out and then you go
to the person who is is relevant to what
you found out and you say what do you
think about this but it's a little
different when it's the access light a
slight slightly more a direct book plug
yeah
this book is about the campaign which
many of you all followed and saw but
what you get from it is a behind the
scenes look pull back the curtain to see
what it's like to be a correspondent on
the campaign trail what your lives are
like what the campaign was like behind
the scenes how did they treat reporters
what are the things they they said that
may have been appropriate or not and
then in these weird history-making
moments what is it like to have to put
something like that on television and
this was odd because this is a tape that
it with language that you can't put on
TV of a presidential candidate bragging
it seems about being able to assault
women and they let you do it because
you're a star
and so I I see the tape I exclaim loudly
in the executive office where I'm being
shown it oh my god did Donald Trump just
say you can grab them by the butt I said
the word and them in the moment and my
boss looks at me and she's like yes he
did we need the campaign to comment on
it and we're gonna put it on TV right
after you get that comment so get a
comment write a script and let's get it
on television and so I I II male hope
and Jason and the email is hope Hayek's
and Jason Miller who were the
communications team on the Trump
campaign and the email word for word is
in the book and it's something like you
know mr. Trump said said you can grab
them by them and he also talked about
effing a married woman and word-for-word
the things he said do you have a comment
they did not respond but then I have to
figure out how to put all these these
raided our things into pg-13 format for
daytime cable news TV and so I think I
I'd grab them by the P were sexual
advances which is totally not fair to
sexual advances
yeah and I mean it's fascinating looking
back in it now because it just it seemed
like if anything was gonna break this
campaign this was gonna break the
campaign the whole place went silent
dark Kellyanne Conway cancelled her TV
appearances which at the time was
unheard of but yeah it's interesting to
look back on it now especially
especially considering what's happening
in the media campaign and now the
president's weighing in on Al Franken
and talking about a tape but completely
ignoring the fact that he has his own
anyway questions yeah there are
microphones in the center and we can
cease and desist with my questions and
get to yours but we should keep them
since we don't talk a lot of time to
questions not statements yeah first
question is how would you rate the job
that the gentleman who interviewed you
had done was he tough enough I think it
could have been a bit tougher to be
honest and the second question is many
of Donald Trump's most of Donald Trump's
policies adversely affect the people who
voted for him do you think that those
people will maybe by the next election
come to the realization that they voted
for someone that's doing them in um you
know I don't know you're right some of
the the policies that he's spoken about
or enacted the D regulations or the
rollback of regulations could
potentially affect them in a negative
way when it comes to just EPA standards
the gutting of Obamacare is gonna affect
a lot of people this tax plan could
potentially raise the taxes of the lower
class and middle class down the line
that might not happen though until after
the next election cycle for those
rollbacks to cease we don't have that
full bill voted on yet so it could
change I you know I don't know and me
depends on job creation do people do
they have jobs it's a job better than
the job they had before do they want to
continue giving him a four more years
for
another chance to try and push things
through I don't know depends I wanted to
thank you for being here I admired your
coverage and I hope you keep at it and I
wanted to ask how in the world do you
put up with these comments from the
other side when you offer them to try to
give a balance and you know it's
nonsense
can you do any better how can the
network's do any better in the future
well I have to reject the premise the
other side is not we here's the thing
about about reporters and and and
journalists and it's a good reminder
we're not out to convince anybody how to
vote it's not our job to convince Trump
voters not to vote for Trump again it's
not our job to convince Democrats to
vote for Democrats it's our job to give
you all the information that that is out
there to to fact-check where we need to
fact-check to contextualize where we
need to contextualize to give you
everything you need to make a the the
the decision that you want to make so
when people come on my show and and they
don't have the facts behind them I try
to push back regardless of whether or
not they're a democrat or republican
it's tough right now though because
there's a lot of people have a lot of
feel like they have a lot of license to
just say fake news when they decide they
don't like something or they there's a
fact that they don't like and that's
really problematic because it it allows
people to just decide that anything they
don't want to hear they don't have to
hear and they don't have to believe and
that is going to I think negatively
affect all of us in the future so my
plea to all of you and thank you for
asking this because I can give my plea
is to do your best to police your
Facebook feeds your Twitter feeds
whatever social media you use and to be
very critical when you look at certain
articles and and make sure that you're
getting accurate information and you
aren't just reading the things that you
want to hear and that you do take a
moment to hear the other side as well
and have conversations with people maybe
they didn't vote the same way you did
but I think it's better to understand
everyone and and come to a place where
we can talk again and accept a shared
set of facts again so we can make better
decisions or good decisions in the
future if you don't disagree with
something in your newsfeed you're doing
it wrong
watching the news should be an
experience of dissonance not constantly
it shouldn't be comfortable thank you
sometimes I watched the daily press
meetings with Sara and I'm wondering I
just want to get up and like strangle
her so I'd like to know how you guys
don't get up and strangle her well first
of all we'd get arrested and that's a
good reason one of the reasons the White
House it's always been a the that podium
has always been a place where a press
secretary will try and spin the news in
their favor that's just the way things
are done this is I think taking it to a
absurd degree there are times where
questions aren't answered or there
they're just they're there either she
says I'll get back to you and she never
gets back to you or she just makes it
about the Democrats suddenly even though
you're asking about Donald Trump or the
Republicans or she's denying the things
that he has said so yeah it's it's
extraordinarily extraordinarily
frustrating I wonder how valuable those
briefings are personally thank you
about then what we're in the same boat I
think every time somebody spins it's not
great for anybody I believe the no spin
zone is available as the slogan
hi so I'm a journalist student and I
read your book when it first came out
and you mentioned that you never had a
background in political journalism but
you start out as a weather girl and that
that kind of helped you cover Donald
Trump better because you didn't have
that background in DC pundit shree but
how do you feel that that whole you know
swamp sort of affected the coverage of
Donald Trump and why people didn't
expect his victory I I worked for the
Weather Channel I was chased tornadoes I
was never actually allowed to do the
weather because I don't understand the
meteorology I'm not a meteorologist but
I covered the news with the weather and
before that I was a local news reporter
for a long time and then obviously a
foreign correspondent I think that it
was beneficial going to 2016 because I
was able to see with fresh eyes the
campaign and the support that he was
getting and the enthusiasm he received
without all the baggage of oh these are
the way things have always been done and
he can't possibly survive this because
so and so didn't survive this so I
thought it was really beneficial I think
that that is partially what happened
during 2016 and and some of my most
revered colleagues who are political
people who do live in DC have admitted
as such saying you know part of the
reason we didn't see Donald Trump coming
is because we just believed everything
all of our hype everything that we had
seen come before in Washington and it
how important it is to get out there and
on the and be on the road and not just
rely on polls actually talk to people
and see something smell something feel
something be inside those rallies and
get a sense of the momentum and the
movement so that's also part of the
reason why I didn't go to DC myself
there was a few things he was one of
them but one of the other ones was that
I just I think it's better to to talk
about it from the outside and to try and
maintain the fresh eyes I had in 2016
thank you thank you and also
congratulations on your wedding
thank you
hello I'm Marsha Reisman and it's a
pleasure to meet you I've been watching
you since you started and it's really
fun to see a new person you've developed
into a really wonderful news reporter
thanks very much go back to Sunday
November 6 okay that morning on all the
news stations everyone was reporting
that it was killer ease Hillary's to
lose she killed her each time that's
interesting
there was Hillary's to lose and the
percentages of her winning were across
the board 60 70 80 all the way up to one
ABC reporter said 98 percent what I
should watch NBC well what happened I
mean I think she wrote a book called
what happened that's intellimouse the
polls were wrong
they weren't totally wrong they just
were wrong enough to lose or not lose
the election but miss called the
election I believe it was November 6 it
might have been the day before that
James Comey came out and said the
investigation the second investigation
into her emails was done here I was
talking to a senior Clinton aide who
said that they felt that that was the
worst thing that could have happened
because it brought the emails not not
the reopening which they didn't like
either but then the closing because
instead of bringing closure to that it
brought it back up again and it made
people remember it and if there was
remember it the Access Hollywood tape
was really bad for Trump really really
really really really really really bad
for Trump and the only thing that kind
of got him out of that hole after 50
former and current Republican lawmakers
were saying either drop out or I won't
vote for you was the reopening of the
emails and what that did and I'm not
saying that that that was the nail in
the coffin for Clinton but what that did
was it enabled moderate Republicans or
Republicans who were on the fence
Republicans who did not want to vote for
Donald Trump to say I'm gonna vote for
him because I can't vote for somebody
who might be under federal investigation
which is ironic but we didn't know at
the time the donald trump was under
investigation because the FBI didn't
inform anybody and there's questions
about what's the double standard for
there so the polls were wrong just
enough and i think that you know there's
a bunch of failings the clinton campaign
didn't go to michigan when they probably
should have gone to michigan they didn't
make sure that their blue wall was gonna
stand the Comey investigation didn't
help what was going on with russia we
still don't know i think we're still a
bit away from figuring out exactly what
happened on november 8th and why and why
donald trump ultimately won but you
can't discount the enthusiasm that he
had I mean people just loved him yeah
the ones that did unbelievable thank you
thank you
unfortunately all good things must come
to an end I'm so sorry because this
conversation is absolutely very engaging
any thank you very much
[Applause]